you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing a
15-2 game so let's see what we get all
right a French let's try to turn it into
something other than a French like a
Kings Indian attack
so far so good I may be going for e5
shortly but first let's still retain
some options with my EEP on planning on
g3 but let's make this Universal move
first
if they take then I could come out along
this diagonal all right I'm going to go
for it
g3 Bishop g2 it is okay
making the standard moves first not
budging with any of my queenside pawns
some type of play could turn into a race
position that's a little bit awkward
okay so stopping II five altogether hmm
well at some point I could just be
threatening to win material with e5
I'll need castles and rook to e1 and I
believe I want to go with my rook to e1
let's get this in rook e1 also allows
for a knight reposition to f1 so let's
see
like is in a think not sure what
candidate moves there are four black
I'll be looking at rookie one and if
Queen c7 I could really insist on trying
to get in this advance so let's start
with it
threatening to win the material the fork
right now probably the fastest I've
played the opening and sometime
so Queen c7 Queen c7 Queenie - I could
insist on trying to get this in will
black capture I don't think that that
would be a good idea I could always
recapture and then the threat is still
there and so in the end you know you're
still having to address this idea and my
third ranked pawn has been exchanged for
whites blacks fourth rank bone
okay so they're sidestepping the fork
however they are preventing me from
getting this advance in okay well I play
e5 the knights going to move to one of
these - I imagine d7 as it's the more
reliable home and then I don't know that
I really have a good way to defend my e5
pawn I think I would just be dropping it
three minor pieces are hitting it in my
queen
un'ytu she isn't a good defender would
be different if the Queen and rook were
switched but Yi 594 Queen e2 they could
take Knight takes Knight takes and my
queen isn't going to take so I'm going
to hold off on e5 I think I need a
little bit more support I definitely
want to keep the Queen zone
and so with that said I believe I want
to go for Queenie to Knight f1 and then
unprepared for f4 because when it's hit
a third time I could then develop my
bishop so I think before I play e5 the
short story here is that I need my queen
on e2 and my knight on f1 now something
I'm questioning is whether or not that's
I don't know far-fetched I don't think
so let's start with Queen to e2 it is a
developing move after all and who knows
maybe maybe black captures or pushes
we'll see if d4 I'll be a bit hesitant
to play e5 I think because okay so we do
have that so as I was just going to say
if I play e5 I am attacking the knight
but I'm inviting him to the d5 square
okay
at the same time if I don't play e5
might black just play e5 and then I'll
be needing to play on the Kings side
with f4 hmm okay it's getting it's
definitely getting sharpen I definitely
need to calculate here you five it's
true I give up this square pot I open up
the diagonal for my Bishop and I stop
black from playing e5 so suppose II five
and then it's attacked a third time with
Knight g4 Knight d7 I think I think I
need to play Knight b3 and allow this
pawn to be captured and in exchange in
exchange for it I get the c5 pawn and if
they don't come straight in for that
capture right away then at least I have
Bishop f4 to defend and then I could
reroute my knight I'm going to go for
this let me just double-check hang on e5
Knight d7 Knight b3 Knight takes pawn
let's just say Knight takes that's nice
news for my bishop I'll take on c5 and I
could pivot up out on the e-file the e4
square I'm going to go for this so I'm
looking for a counter-attack against c5
he could be one the e5 pawn could be one
if black wants hmm when I didn't take a
to account his night on d7 is defending
c5 but I should be able to still
undermine the defense of the c5 pawn I
should have looked at that a bit more
closely yeah
I mean I could play Knight c4 but mmm
maybe maybe that's actually not so bad
maybe that is the way to go
yeah because black would probably be a
bit crazy
to play b5 you know this is a one thing
I question is the stability of the piece
on c4 okay well in the end they're not
looking to target e5 so I may be able to
now go in this direction with Knight f1
h4 Knight h2 Knight g4
want more to consider well they ever
play f6 I could be assured that these
two pieces will be happy we'll have some
new prospects along the e-file
this move while tempting to try and
secure a knight on c4 I don't think he
can last long on c4 and also I have to
bear in mind that if I'm playing a four
I'm giving up b4 and this can be a great
bother having a black knight exert
pressure on c2 I don't want that
responsibility for my queen that said I
don't think I want to go to c4 with my
knight and so I'll probably go Knight f1
knight eh - yeah let's do that right
away keeping a nice structure no no
serious weaknesses on the Queen side by
bishops now free
let's see what black does they have to
get their queen side pieces working so
okay they're headed for b5
well he's not contributing let's set the
H pond in motion it's a big race black
is looking to attack me on the queenside
and I'm looking to attack on the
kingside here night h2 and IG for H 5
once H 5 is played or if H P H if H 5 is
played there's a big question for black
you know do you allow H 6 or not and I'm
not sure what what the best answer is to
that I've had my own difficulties
playing the black end of a similar
structure if you're playing H 6 to
prevent light from playing h 6 this pawn
is sticking out like a sore thumb
we could easily see two minor pieces
converging there and P sacrifices
immediately come to mind if you allow h6
then that means f6 will be a whole and I
could look for a dark square bishop
exchange
and then maybe just kind of you know
weasel in some way for checkmate on g7
just the rough idea
they felt the need to take some action
in the center clearly
my first impression well aside from them
taking action in the center here I feel
that it's a bit inconsistent to have
rook be aid and then all of a sudden
some play on f6 okay
let's have a look at the squares that
are weakened with that last movie six
and G six
okay well they're threatening to win
upon they are hitting it three times I'm
guessing I have to just take you know
I'm thinking I have to just take so
let's just take I have so many options
there
I'll still be looking for this okay well
I was thinking taking with the pond is
more important as awkward as that may
seem I mean it closes in this I guess
either ways you look at it there's
there's going to be some problem and the
big problem I'm seeing for black are
these squares here these are now holes
and I could maybe look to pivot about on
the e4 square looking at some more
direct stuff I have Bishop g5 however I
think I want to keep this option open
maybe my knight wants to go there maybe
my bishop
I definitely want this guy playing and
how does he ever get playing Bishop on
c8 I'm not sure that's for them to
figure out
okay well I could look at something like
this if this pawn moves the Knights
unprotected ideas like this bring to
mind I would be taking the night with
check I should keep my eyes peeled for
stuff along this diagonal the ref pawn
has budged their king is still on g8 a
night on g5 a queen coming to h5 h7 is
potentially sensitive I could look for
this stuff what about the things that
black potentially has any sacrifice
against GC g 3 isn't working i have this
square covered
watching over these squares definitely
don't want this night
causing me any problems I'm pretty sure
right around here the computer would
already be lighting up at some there's
some strong continuation let's consider
I guess they're looking for this or
first here and then well I don't know I
could probably start with 9g for hit the
Queen and then go from there yeah let's
do this
I'm queen g6 hitting my knight I could
move my knight just keep making forward
moves and with that I'm threatening
Bishop efore
okay they're really asking for trouble I
think because now when Bishop e4 hits
h6 is an issue also my knight is within
checking distance so this paw never
budges Knight h6 currently my knight on
g4 is hit I'm thinking Knight g5 Queen
is close to trapped
yeah that Queen is very close to trapped
all right I'm thinking on Knight g5
they'd have six
hmm 95 Knight f6 I could exchange
Knights and then always drop in here you
know I'm just going to play this okay
now f2 is a little bit sensitive but
nothing that I I don't think that that
could be taken advantage of so let's
start with Knight g5 they have to be
very very careful here one one wrong
slip and it's already game over like the
tempting h6 loses the Queen these
Knights are covering so much ground
Knight f6 the Queen has to feel pretty
awkward but at least there is a threat
against my knight it's not a strictly
defensive move well in the end can I not
just be winning upon as well I may end
up in some pin if I try to go pawn
grabbing
you
this is one of those positions where I
shouldn't feel the need to
when by tactical means I could resort to
positional like some kind of a strategic
approach I do have a good structure I
have the the better structure here this
is a very unhealthy pawn but there
really does feel like there should be
some type of knockout right around the
corner let's see
under 814 black
Knight f6 is the only thing I'm thinking
this isn't working I'd take the knight
with Chuck easy to go wrong for Black
Knight f6 Knight takes Knight Queen has
to recapture as otherwise this is
collapsing Knight f6 Knight takes Knight
Queen takes Knight I think I still play
here to e4 then on h6 where's my Knight
calling
maybe it's my knight who belongs back on
e4 I could look to target II uh this guy
and maybe I could win that Knight f6
Knight takes Knight Queen takes Knight
and then Knight e4 hitting the Queen and
c5 where would she go hmm you know
clearly they they sense the pressure
here biggest think of the game
really not 100% on what I'm doing Knight
f6 Knight takes Queen takes oh boy that
is way too slow the Queen is just dead
okay so I'm pretty sure they see this
and they're looking to get two minor
pieces for the Queen
yeah otherwise I don't see what Bishop
II form I'm picking up the Queen and
they're prepared to take stakes and then
discovered attack and then they get this
guy
it should never be enough but I guess
that's what their idea is here trying
trying to strike some imbalance in the
position so I doubt that there's
anything better than Bishop b4
let's do it
so what's their next move here if their
idea is you know to allow the Queen to
be captured and then this because they
must have seen this I'm guessing you
know this rook move was played
to not challenge either night when I
have basically everything breathing down
the black Kings neck
well their hesitation tells me that
maybe they did overlook this move we
could definitely say that some time was
wasted here
rook b8 handfull moves later rook to e8
how productive of and developing move is
it really Bishop d7 so
it's definitely a different a different
approach for a black setup different
story of f6 was played without rook to
b8 even so you know they just resigned
it's a short one
okay well let's have a look at it I
guess they just miss this idea as
mentioned I said it more than once it's
pretty easy to go wrong I mean one one
one little slip and that could be it
let's have a look at the analysis and
see what a kind of different approach
there is for Team black and let's also
make sure what I'm doing is okay as well
so French defense well Kings Indian
attack
I don't know this this felt a little bit
awkward
I played the black side where you just
go here my castle and then you're not
too quick to Castle kingside you kind of
hold off in the event that he five is
played you know I have some space over
here on the Kings side but black has not
yet committed as king over here so
there's still possibilities for let's
say b6
let's just say Queenie to Bishop c8 in
queenside castle you know with maybe
even h6 and g5 ideas looking to commit
my king so it's a big big decision to
castle I would go as far as saying that
the decision with the bishop is big as
well because you know eventually this is
going to be a threat what ended up
happening in the game is he had to move
a second time to c7 and just just to
parry this fork idea so some time was
wasted and to be wasting time in a
position type like this where it's a
race and the element of time is probably
the number one factor in these race type
positions were you know will typically
black looks to play on the Queen side
and I'm looking to play on the Kings
side to attack but black tried to combat
my e5 pawn head-on with f6
and that just allowed me to well it
created some weaknesses within blacks
position and these two squares and
specifically I'm thinking Bishop e7 is
better
I like the these flexible moves they
should be seven Queen c7 B six Bishop b7
and you know wait wait to see if I'm in
fact going to play e5 or not don't be
too quick to commit the king yeah I
think I could already put the engine on
this will this will be a big moment
right here and I guess we're following
one of the top a top game here from 1999
which turned out to be a drop so this
this is a move here and then 95 no games
in the databases with that once it go
Knight d7 just have a quick look
oops let's just have a quick look at how
this game played out once this decision
was played r1 c5 was played so we're
following this game I just want to get a
feel yeah I want to get a feel for you
know the different Knight position night
on d7 compared to a knight on d5
Wow it's pretty sharp stuff let's put
the ow let's put the engine on this
feels very very promising for light just
these weaknesses over here night jumping
in yeah I mean the result is a draw but
I could see that oh you got to be
kidding that's the end of the game they
agree to a draw in this position oh my
goodness this is when one of the more
lively positions you're going to see I
mean this doesn't say this doesn't speak
draw to me at all they don't have black
doesn't have their dark square Bishop
White has a dark square bishop and there
are these holes here okay well I didn't
get too far that game all right let's
see let me put the engine on from this
point and see what other things we can
take away from this so it's not a big
fan of my night to f1 move and why is
that what does it want to do wants to
play Knight here but I thought I would
just be dropping this pawn okay I could
I could be taking on c5 two different
ways to target that I suppose b6 to
defend okay some some sharp stuff here
huh oh wow
look at this
oh yeah
dangerous very very
dangerous suggesting already to give up
the Queen
interesting okay so I could do better
than the night f1 move as you can see
it's not it's not a big fan of it at the
same time this is a position type that
the computer can maybe get wrong and
these you know slow slow building up
type games where the pieces are steadily
improving and drifting towards the the
king
I've had some games playing against
computer where I've sacrificed a piece
in this f6 square let me just make some
passing moves to illustrate of course
black will be doing something more
productive but just to highlight I've
done something like this before
well I'm still picturing that the bishop
is on e7 and that we have a dark square
Bishop exchange so this is this is a
little bit awkward to have the bishop on
this square but if you could just
envision a dark square Bishop exchange
and after this pawn recaptures it's
really supporting a night jump into this
square and the end result is that white
has established a great thorn in blacks
position on f6 upon that
is worth far more than a single point
but just just to highlight a different
one of the attacking ideas a bit
available for white
this capture and then a night dropping
in to have six and then getting the the
pieces over here going right after the
king
okay well night f1 rook to b8 is what
the computer is suggesting okay now h4
f6 okay not a fan of f6 it it's it's
tough to really suggest something I it's
my it's my feeling let's take with the
knight on f6
I mean suppose they just go here
b5 seems like the right kind of follow
up right play rook b8 b5 night here I'm
not sure if these are the most
purposeful moves around but you know
just trying to crack something open over
here these pieces are drifting in you
know this is a tough one for the
computer to assess yeah already
sacrifices on h6
isn't clean out maybe even a move look
at that it is you know you could
sacrifice another piece it's brutal
stuff so they went with f6 and then
there's there's two holes you know as
soon as the recapturing at the pond or
recapturing with the piece these squares
here cannot be defended by any black
pawn so and of the two this is the one
that I'm looking to pivot about on hmm 9
h 2i g 4 9 g 5 + 2 I guess they have to
go in for that minor 2 minor pieces for
the Queen if was to play out I mean
what's the computer suggesting h6 Bishop
d2 not a move I would really be playing
what if I just go straight in for this I
guess it's still kind of messy huh I'd
maybe have to be a bit patient I can't
see myself playing Bishop d2 here Bishop
d2 just giving up the night and taking
and now doing this
Oh to be pretty accurate there but I
could just go straight in for this and
well they're getting three minor pieces
aren't they yeah they maybe should have
played it out a little bit more I don't
know maybe I don't know I thought that
that was the idea that they had to get
the two minor pieces or and then some as
we're seeing the computer suggesting h6
and maybe they get three minor pieces
and I get the Queen in a pond or two hmm
what were to look out oh this variation
the one that I said I wasn't exactly
sure what I would do if Knight f6 was
played hmm yeah if Knight f6 it's
reading plus one I was eyeing up just
the capture and then a Knight to e4 move
you know have to be careful about how to
defend c5 Queen here there's Bishop f4
or even f4 I guess I could chase the
Queen away from defense of c5 I wouldn't
be I wouldn't be too concerned about
these pawns moving away from my king I
have a very active pieces and they're
not they're not in any position to
organize some attack against my king so
that's what could happen if they played
Knight f6 I could take here this is no
good because of f4 but on Queen f5 now
once you go back to g5 with this I don't
want to draw hmm have to be coming up
with something else I guess we can look
to target a six fish of h3 rook e8 and
now here yeah with the difference being
there is no Queen f5 now that's
interesting it's not so
and to to see this this mo vert saw that
common isn't the word it's atypical to
pull the bishop off of this diagonal but
yeah collector strike at this capturing
right away runs into some trouble
awkward pin the first pitch of h3 and
then this this is much cleaner now f4
clean here Wow Wow okay let's get in a
little bit crazy you have to work all
those out if I'm not winning this pawn
for sure and I'd be a bit more hesitant
to make these advances on the Kings side
I definitely want to hold something in
my hand here I want to have some
material if I'm going to be making these
Kings side concessions but yeah well
they ended up just dropping their Queen
here
easy easy to do easy to go wrong in this
opening and some time wasted again the
bishop Bishop to d6 move it's playable
of course but my preference is the
already mentioned Bishop e6 Bishop e7
Queen c7 and you're just going about it
where you don't commit your king so soon
and I believe there's even one other
more than one I'm sure but I've seen a
system where the King Knight doesn't
play to f6
you know already seeing this right here
black in black and go about a setup
where it's c5 Knight c6
Bishop e7 and Knight d7
excuse me Bishop d6 and Knight to e7 in
a way to combat the e5 move is by
playing f6 which is not without its
weaknesses of course but it doesn't
allow this space invader pawn doesn't
allow white to establish a pawn on e5 so
just kind of giving you a feel for a
different setup that black can be going
with on Bishop d6 if you are going to go
with that maybe the knight is better
suited on e7 which stays clear of the F
pawn so he could look to fight for
control that e5 square
okay well as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care bye